[Music]
yeah
okay thank you yeah I'm Rob and we're
going to talk about Bayesian deep
learning with ten percent of the weights
for those of you are interested or more
interested in their laptops like all the
slides are on my github like I upload
them half an hour ago so we can look
along neural networks all kind of fluffy
all kind of nice I was like Friday I was
at the tutorial session I think within
earshot I overheard three conversations
about neural networks like today I was
for lunch I went out to catch some
breath and I struck up two conversations
about neural networks people are writing
blogs about them they're being hyped in
the media but in my opinion we have two
challenges left and those two challenges
are uncertainties and millions of
parameters when we want to make a
prediction we want to know the
uncertainty and neural networks have
millions of parameters they are called
over parameterised beasts and this talk
I'm going through the address those two
problems uncertainty why would we want
to know the uncertainty table a typical
application is medical application if
your doctor tells you you need the
surgery that wouldn't you want to know
the uncertainty wouldn't you want to
know the uncertainty by which the model
kind of predicts disease or not or tumor
or not an autonomous driving when we
when our autonomous car breaks before
when our dash cam sees a pedestrian
wouldn't we know and want to know the
uncertainty if we're highly certain the
- pedestrian over there
we need the sudden break it were highly
uncertain there's a pedestrian over
there we need to control our lidar out
of fun example of curve is of course
Bitcoin if you're putting all your money
on Bitcoin tomorrow wouldn't you want
the holy uncertainty
yeah okay a consequence of this
uncertainty stuff is adversarial
examples so here as heard of a through
several examples before yeah so in the
left column or no network is classifying
all these images correctly it's a bus
it's a pyramid or a soap dispenser and
in the right column the neural network
is predicting everything as ostrich only
by adding imperceptible noise and that
is the thing we want to prevent well we
have no network in production we don't
want this weird we don't want these
weird classifications we want to know a
network that says ok here I'm highly
certain this is a school bus and here we
wonder no network to say we don't know
if you're a customer facing application
in here you just don't give a prediction
back or you give a prediction back and
you say they're Hardy uncertain the
other problem that motivates us is that
the millions of parameters if we go to
embedded applications we do have small
memory we do have small computes so
every parameter that we can drop pruning
neural network pruning means literally
dropping parameter setting prevalence to
zero so for every parameter that we can
drop we safe computes obvious example is
real-time inference we want to do
real-time inference every neuron every
parameter every layer that we can drop
less computes now I'm kind of a little
bit of curious to to to you so who here
has read or read a blog or a paper about
neural networks before
who here has trained the neural network
before can be in chaos and who here has
ever put a neural network in production
yeah so it's it's lessons and actually
so so this talk is a little bit about
that gap I feel those two challenges are
preventing from putting it preventing us
from putting it in production if those
examples didn't motivate you then for
the coders this is kind of the
pseudocode of my talk in my opinion for
every training any neural network this
is kind of the pseudocode we care about
we make a model we trained us some data
if we go for an embedded
we prune it pruning means dropping
parameters and then this lines what we
care about model to predict input goes
in prediction and uncertainty comes out
and the approach that we're going to
take is we're not going to do something
new we're not going to I'm not going to
talk about the latest archive paper or
the latest research we're going back to
basics we're going back to base rule
eighteenth-century
we're going back to variational
inference for those who know what it
means but it has been around since 1993
and forgetting uncertainties in our
predictions we're going back to
information theory
we're going back to Shannon's
information theory from like 70 years
ago or 60 years ago don't make the
basics what are we going to do we are
going to apply Bayes rule and no slide
without on the Bayesian deep learning is
finished without the neon sign so I also
have the neon sign Bayes rule says we
have a prior belief we have a model and
then the model has parameters over which
we have a prior belief we observe some
data in our likelihood and then we have
a posterior belief and actually this is
not something new we've been using Bayes
rule all the time
so who here has ever done rich
regression or weight decay or l2
regularization pretty much all the hands
go up right when we do weight decay a
rich regression or l2 regularization we
were in fact using Bayes rule using
those methods were saying we have a
Gaussian prior on our parameters and
then the thing we did is that we used to
cast a gradient descent to find one of
the parameter vectors that minimize our
loss function and now the difference
that we're going to make today the
difference that we're going to make
today is that we're not going to find
one parameter vector but we're going to
approximate our posterior and sample
many parameter vectors and you might
rightfully ask why would we want to do
that because if we approximate our
posterior
this approximation will tell us which
which parameters we can drop and if we
can sample many parameters from this
approximation we can use it to get the
uncertainty so we want to approximate an
example many parameters from it let's
get a little bit of a visual like
perspective on that this is our
old-style neural network we have a
vector times a matrix gives not a vector
times not a matrix gives an output and
now the difference that we're going to
make today is that instead of affirming
these parameters we are going to infer
distribution for each parameter so you
see the change I like it a lot yeah we
make a Gaussian approximation and just
to get a little bit of clear just to get
it very concise a Gaussian has two
parameters it has a mu and a sigma mu
stels
okay where is the most probable value of
the parameter and the Sigma says like
how how much do we believe in our
posterior that it can fluctuate so
instead of inferring one parameter
vector for each parameter we're going to
infer the MU and Sigma and how does this
look like and we where did this is or
this is the only slide with mathematics
in my in my presentation so don't be
afraid so we talked about the
approximations and samples but but what
it really boils down to is that we have
to minimize a loss function we make a
neural network and we do gradient
descent on a loss function our old loss
function was this we had a
classification loss and some l2 penalty
and our new loss function like the only
thing that will change is that we still
have a classification loss we still have
an l2 penalty same and now we also have
a penalty on the Sigma's and by
minimizing on this loss function we'll
make an approximate
this will help us for the pruning and
this will help us for the uncertainties
let's get a little bit intuition on the
mathematics so this is the new loss
function we have a loss on the location
of the weights so hey this and this is
kind of the old picture that we had in
mind we want to low classification loss
in a low l2 regularization and we now
also have a loss on the Sigma's and this
new loss function on the sigma says okay
each sigma should be close to the prior
so for example in all my code examples
and in all kind of examples that you'll
read about in papers we just have a unit
Gaussian prior so the prior for the
sixth mass is one and then this loss
function just draws all Sigma's to one
and for a neural network like Woo's
weights are on the order of 10 to the
minus 2 10 to the minus 3 the Sigma of
one is large basically saying I don't
know anything about this parameter value
so to get everyone back on track what do
we really care about uncertainties and
pruning how do we do that
Bayesian inference how do we do that we
approximate the parameter posterior how
do we do that for every parameter value
we find mu and Sigma and how do we do
that we minimize the loss function on
the previous slide that's it
uncertainties so how would we get an
uncertainty for our prediction and for
that I want to do a little bit of a show
of hands because we need a metric to
define our uncertainty in our
predictions so let's say tomorrow today
we're going to bet Bitcoin or all our
money on Bitcoin and the model is going
to make two predictions for if we're
going to win tomorrow the prediction on
the left or the prediction on the right
which prediction would you rather have
in other words which prediction has the
lowest uncertainty hands for the picture
on the left and hands for the picture on
the right exactly we want we want the
prediction on the right and then Claude
Shannon Ennis teachers on information
theory told us is that
if we want to measure this we should
calculate the entropy the entropy of
this distribution is highly uncertain so
it's high an entropy of this
distribution we are very certain so we
are highly yeah we are very certain so
we have a low value of the entropy we
also need a metric by which we're going
to prune our networks and to remember so
we went from this old-style neural
network to this new style neural network
now what pruning looks like is that
these are all neural network and pruning
really does this we are dropping
parameters we are setting parameters to
zero but now we need a metric by which
we're going to drop these parameters and
in what order
like which parameter can we drop right
away like it adds nothing to our model
and which parameter is kind of important
for our model and we we only want to
drop it in the in the very end and the
metric by which you're going to do that
is the probability of being zero because
dropping a parameter is really like
saying okay I have the value of zero so
when we go to choose which parameters to
drop we just drop the parameters with
the highest probability of being zero so
another show of hands would we rather
drop so this is these are two posterior
these are the posterior with two
parameters probably the probability
density and the value of this parameter
so which parameter would we rather drop
would we'd rather drop the upper one or
the lower one ends up for the upper one
ends up for the lower one yeah we would
want to rather drop the parameter from
the lower chart because it has a high
probability of being zero
so now let's have some fun let's do this
on data you talk about deep learning so
we should do something with em nests and
then we have two data sets
I think deep learning is mainly applied
to image classification and time series
classification so we have the cipher ten
data sets and the UK are EKG data sets
fun thing about the EKG data sets is
that they have only 500 training samples
and we're going to fit a neural network
of half a million weights to this 500
training samples and that is added
benefit of being patient's Bayesian
Bayesian don't of it
so Amnesty here has worked with Emily's
before probably a lot like some people
call it the hello world of deep learning
this is what Emily's looks like it's the
handwritten digits of like 0 to 9 this
is the site for 10 dataset so it's
common images of 10 classes of objects
in the real world and these are examples
of our EKG datasets and then our results
for a pruning so remember for every
distribution we have mu and Sigma and we
can calculate the probability of that
parameter being 0 in the posterior and
that means we can just order our
parameters we can like order our
parameters by the probability of being 0
and start dropping them start dropping
them start dropping them until we reach
the 10% because that's the title of this
talk and then we can see what the
validation accuracy does and that is
such a plot is what we would end up with
so here we start on the left and we
order them by the probability of being 0
and as we drop more parameters as we
drop more parameters the validation
accuracy stays kind of the same and only
at about yeah kind of when we have 10%
of the parameters left only then does
the validation accuracy goes down so
this plot is saying if we're using only
10% of the weights we can still expect
kind of
very good validation accuracy and the
same thing we can do for so far so far
as more real-world I guess then amnesty
cipher has okay let's be skeptical maybe
at about 85 so 15 percent of the way
it's only then will a validation
accuracy go down our third dataset was
the EKG dataset and as I said the fun
thing about this data set is that we
have only 500 samples EKGs I think it's
a time series of 128 time stamps and we
have only 500 samples the validation set
by the way is 4,000 samples so it is a
good representative of the validation
accuracy and the fun thing about this
this chart actually is that we see that
when we've dropped like 90 percent of
parameters we still have good validation
accuracy maybe when we drop even 95 or
97 percent of the parameters we still
have good validation accuracy and only
then does the validation actually drop
and that is because we have only 500
training samples so a lot of our
parameters in our posterior will have
very high standard deviation because we
don't have any data to to learn
something about them or to find a value
for them also some of the results for
the uncertainties are there this kind of
a weird thing we all have an intuition
for it but how do we I was actually
wondering at home or thinking at home
how how can we actually see that we are
uncertain so figure it ok for image
classification is a little bit easier
because for example for images we know
that if we add noise we should be more
uncertain we know that for example if we
warp our images we should be more
uncertain if we rotate our images I'm
going we're going to do this for M NIST
and we always draw it right top down so
if we're going to rotate our images we
expect more uncertainty because our data
was simply not trained on that or our
model was simply not trained on the data
so what is going to happen in this in
this
if in this animation we see your
eminence digits and we're going to add
more and more noise in the title it says
what is the entropy so our metric for
the uncertainty and the title is green
if it's being classified correctly and
red if it's classified incorrectly for
those of you who like me are more visual
the edge of the image is going to color
according to uncertainty so black means
very certain and white means very
uncertain this is what we would expect
as we as we add more noise the entropy
is going up we are making more incorrect
classifications and also kind of the
edges they become brighter so we are
more uncertain and this is a fun thing
because like it also is in our intuition
but if the uncertainty goes up so do the
misclassifications you go up so if
you're a customer facing application
then what you like if you have a
customer facing application what you
might do is that when the entropy or the
uncertainty region reaches a certain
threshold you just don't return a
prediction you tell your customer hey
for whatever input you gave me like I'm
uncertain I don't know what to predict
and this is actually preventing those at
for several examples from happening
because then you return like no
prediction same thing happens with
rotation so we always write top down so
as of course as we rotate images
misclassifications increase
uncertainties increase here they you get
like super white and the same thing for
warping yeah and this is also a fun
thing by the way this 9 is kind of
written very oddly I guess we're just
back to the emmys data set so we see
already that even without warping we are
highly uncertain about it so uncertainty
is not always telling you if it's a miss
classification or not
and the same thing will happen as we
warp our images more uncertainty more
misclassifications just more mess this
kind of a situation where we we tell our
customers hey we don't make a prediction
and this is actually very moment I'm
very nervous for I haven't slept well
last night because now I'm going to do a
demo and then most don't go well so
because I have enough time I guess
so what we're going to do is that like
in two minutes I'm going to ask someone
from the audience to draw some Emily's
digits and then I will actually run the
network and see on which prediction it
was certain or uncertain
so how would it look like for example I
can draw for or this is kind of a why I
can draw a tree but I can also draw a
smiley or I can do some Criss crossing I
guess yeah I can draw whatever like what
else could I draw maybe a proper zero
and oh and a fun thing is is that the
Emily's digits are all kind of these
thick lines so I could also draw a
proper five with a thin line and maybe
it's going to classify this five
correctly maybe not because it's demo
but we have a thin line so probably we
expect more uncertainty because like
this is not data that it was trained on
then flow starting up yeah and this is
why you don't do demos life
yeah yeah okay thank you for the tip
yeah and this is exactly what we hope
for because like our smiley it has a
high entropy like it's colored it's
colored according to the uncertainty so
it is getting kind of in the red zone we
have high uncertainty and also the
prediction is incorrect like what would
be a smiley but for example for this
tree like this is a proper M this tree
so we have a low uncertainty fairy blue
and a correct classification Oz for this
five we see a little bit that the
uncertainty goes up not much but you get
a point
yeah so now someone from the audience
can come up and and draw six emily's
digits just someone who has a very like
stable hand who's not going to okay
someone very eager yeah okay you see the
six boxes you can draw six m-miss digits
and also do one with kind of junk so we
can actually see okay now I am saving
thanks for the tip by the way
yeah yeah so what are we seeing here the
six and the nine they are very eminent
like very blue
low uncertainty yeah and then these
scribbles guess this is a nine being
turned this is a nine being flipped and
now we have high uncertainty yeah so
this is what we would expect like proper
anastasius low uncertainty junk high
uncertainty huh yeah because for the
last one you would expect higher
uncertainty maybe then for the nine
being flipped yeah that's right yeah but
this is probably about your trash
holding like right now I'm coloring
these numbers between zero and one point
three but maybe you have a very like
importance a customer application and
then you trash all that 0.2 or maybe
it's kind of everything's okay and then
you threshold at 0.7 and this one would
be included so this is kind of the
number that you want to the entropy or
the uncertainty is kind of the number
that you would want to trash hold on
okay so what are the takeaways of our
discussion what are the takeaways of
this of this presentation for critical
for neural networks are all kind of fine
they're being hyped everyone is talking
about them talking not putting in
production everyone's talking about them
we want to know the uncertainty for
critical predictions we want to know the
uncertainty this makes us robust against
a fresh air'll attacks because like from
certain uncertainty onwards like we just
tell our customers or our like our users
hey we are uncertain everyone to prove
networks for small memory and small
computes I believe in open source so all
the codes is is online on my github I
even have a further reading section for
the people who like to dive a little bit
deeper in the math or the application
and I think the readme of the github
also explains what is happening in the
code stuff and that's it and I'm happy
to take questions so since we've got
plenty of times for questions oh we're
gonna steal the first one when you prune
the network and you remove a wait I'm
assuming in this case you're literally
going all the way until ten percents
left
do you retrain in between no is that a
good idea or a bad idea to retrain would
it maybe add something or will there be
something going wrong if you do that is
that is probably a bad idea because the
neural network is using all these
redundant parameters to actually find
the setting so for example we start with
with the UCR with the EKG dataset we
started with half a million weights and
we can trim it down to 50,000 ways but
if we would have started with 50,000
weights in the first place
it might not have found such such a good
parameter values or such a kind of a
local up to a local minimum so it's
probably a bad idea if you're interested
in this I think two weeks ago Frank
who's our from influence of TZ posted
the blog on this
so I can include a link but he wrote a
blog on this why this is not such a good
idea
so oh wait the blog there's a lot of
questions so we might not get to
everyone but I'll just randomly get the
mic to ollie
I I thought he meant not retraining
forums quit but training continuing
training from that point once you're fun
yeah so the question also to repeat it
for everyone in the audience the
question is you have known elevates we
want to prune them and retrain them a
bit prune them and retrain them a bit
sounds like an awesome idea I don't know
I don't know what to expect I haven't
read anything about it yeah quickly
because yeah so otherwise someone else
you know I would go to the archive but I
don't know if you prune 10% of the or
90% of the way it's exactly you probably
left with very sparse deep neural
network does that give you any insights
and the features or is a really wishful
thinking so the question is if we prune
parameters does it give us insight on
the features that the neural network
learns
maybe maybe I don't know what what is
yeah no it would be an interesting thing
to research yes just a really quick
question because you left lots of the
implementation out I'll definitely look
at your code later but what do you use
for the variational inference part is
like Edward or some other library this
is like so the question is like what I
use for the implementation a pure tensor
flow cool okay only Burton flow okay and
then basically you're just implementing
yourself the way that you prove the
parameters afterwards
Saunders distribution okay and also for
the KL divergence because our prior is
Gaussian and our approximation is prior
Gaussian yeah I see you smiling you get
the point like the math works out yes so
instead of learning a parameter for
foreign parameter you learn a
distribution normal distribution to
parameters and I want to know how does
the inference process work I mean it's a
distribution so how does the how does
the inference
[ __ ] them you have a minister image you
want to guess the number and how does
the the prediction process work I mean
some distribution ah yeah yeah because
its distribution so the question is is
when we have a prediction so let's say
like an analyst digits comes in or like
a an image comes in and we want to make
a prediction and your question is how
would we do that
because we have an approximation and the
answer to that is we sample many weights
so for example we sample our
approximation 10 times we predict 10
times and we average those okay so we're
there be a problem like even you send
for 10 times for the same image there
will be different routes if I if I
predict it for twice yeah but it's not
about those 10 it's not about those
different result
it's about averaging those because that
is we are probably we are then sampling
from the posterior predictive
distribution so we are actually
averaging though those and that is what
gives us our uncertainty so final
question
so Cleo do they put the slide to the
Browning ECG that the court yeah you
planning the ECG tell set the network
chain on ECG data set and the poor man's
the curve the curve the line shot the
slice your question if yeah yeah it's on
the slides I mean yeah so I saw when you
sometimes when you're on the more
parameters the performance is higher
maybe this is more kind of the question
that we want to discuss later if I if I
because it seems like very intimate
thing
you mean this small bump or it goes back
up a little bit yeah I've been thinking
about that too I noticed it too
I guess it's kind of because I have all
kind of world hypotheses which like I
don't want to confuse everyone with so
let's leave it leave it as an open
question so you said that Bayesian
method cannot over fit
so the question invasions is more kind
of a quote that's being thrown around
but but the reason it doesn't over fit
is that for example we have half a
million weights and we have only 500
training samples for the EKG data set
then just a lot of those parameters are
going to have a very high very high
uncertainty very low certainty there's
actually proof that so know maybe that's
not the direction but there's a lot of
parameters with a very high uncertainty
and if we take all of those
uncertainties in into account we can
never over fit because we have only
enough training data to fit a couple of
those parameters I can maybe refer you
to a little bit of a proof in terms of
mathematics to what you were asking for
I'll get a whiteboard ready yeah yeah
I'll link I have the book chapter in
mind it's from the book from Andrew
Gelman Bayesian data analysis and yes
like a pair like a chapter on this I
look it up and I know there might be
time for one more short question short
question like one and part of free short
question
they used for determining the
uncertainty the entropy of the
probabilities across the categories or
the entropy of the distribution of the
most likely category so the question is
is over what distribution the entropy is
being calculated and entropy is being
calculated over all possible predictions
so for over all possible classes so
yeah yeah you don't but then you have
the Herald examples because one softmax
can be that that's also nice intuition
that I have kind of in the back of my
mind one parameter vector can be fooled
by an official attack but if you sample
like tens or hundreds of them
you can't fool them anymore yeah and
also if you're interested and also for
the for the rest in the further reading
section I included actually a paper that
shows this is that SF Rahzel attacks
become stronger or more widespread that
also the uncertainty increases with
strength I believe there will be a small
entourage traveling with you as you're
going to get coffee so just be mindful
okay there are many people I think who
still want to ask questions but I do
want to I don't want to deny you your
coffee break so let's give one more
final round of applause to roll thank
you